you say cyrus et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau coup de fil qui s'inscrit dans
une continuité par rapport aux coups de
fil 8 / pavlov puisqu'on va voir une
nouvelle expérience qui nous permettent
d'aborder un nouveau conditionnement
c'est l'expérience de la boîte de
skinner bruce springsteen est un
psychologue américain
et comme vous l'avez sûrement pas
remarqué à la vue de ces dates il
arrivait juste après pavlov et watson et
donc ses graffs et influencé par lui il
a le sentiment que le conditionnement
classique c'est un petit peu comme un
cas particulier et pour lui la
conséquence d'une action est beaucoup
plus importante que le stimulus qui la
précède dans l'élaboration d'un
comportement ce mec me fais un
expérience dans le début des années 30
où il va mettre un rat dans une boîte et
après il va faire des trucs mais sa
peine dans cette boîte il ya donc un rat
avec un haut-parleur
enfin le veut je suis et lumière agit
stimulus un destructeur de bouffe et un
plancher l'excom plus qu est cette boîte
va nous permettre de façonner le
comportement du rat par un double
système de renforcement bombe sociale je
viens de renforcer les rangs de la salle
de bains et punitions et moi j'ai pas
droit forcément aller enfin ce mois et
qu'un grand les pygmées et les lettres
et renforcement et punitions donc en
fait un renforcement
c'est une conséquence de comportement
qui fait que tu aura tendance à
reproduire le comportement plus souvent
est une punition c'est l'inversé tu
attends a tendance à reproduire le
comportement moins souvent à chaque fois
tu as deux types de renforcement et
punitions quand on veut augmenter la
probabilité qu'un comportement se
produise on l'a dit on va le renforcer
on peut le faire soit en ajoutant un
stimulus ça sera donc arrangements
positifs comme par exemple gagne au
casino mais on peut aussi renforcer
comportement en supprimant simule us
c'est le renforcement négatifs comme le
fait de ne pas devoir faire la vaisselle
on peut aussi diminuer la probabilité
qu'un comportement se produise on va
utiliser le principe de punition même si
skinner ne met pas ce terme à cause de
sa connotation négative
ensuite c'est pareil on à l'ajout de
stimulus qui va donner la punition
positive donc par exemple recevoir une
amende que le retrait de stimulus donc
la punition négative comme aide primaire
desserte
je rappelle donc qu'on dit positif et
négatif à cause de la joue et retrait
d'un stimulus on le but ce n'est pas de
faire tous en même temps parce que sinon
ça marche absolument
d'ailleurs on peut classer les éléments
de renforcement en deux catégories
primaire qui répondent à des besoins de
base genre manger boire etc et
secondaire qui répondent à des besoins
et des envies que tu as acquis genre
large ce conditionnement opérant on
retrouve notamment dans le dressage dans
la pâte dans la patrie et pour skinner
c'est aussi ce qui est à l'origine des
superstitions en eau par exemple si je
passe sous une échelle et qui m'arrive
ensuite un malheur eh ben je veux
associer inconsciemment ou consciemment
mon malheur aux fêtes choix passés sous
les chefs alors qu'il ya de grandes
chances pour que ça n'a rien à voir
alors j'ai pas pu faire qu'avec pavlov
faire un petit lot avec vous parce
qu'ici il faudrait que je réagisse à une
action que vous faites et envoi je me
suis rendu compte que ce processus on
l'avait un petit peu avec eux les like
les abonnements et partage qui agissent
comme comme tout lu tout l'est et
l'ouest un renforcement positif bien
joué pourquoi parce qu'on ajoute une
conséquence cool ce qui va augmenter la
probabilité de faire des vidéos donc si
cette vidéo tu as plus on renforce mois
en la partageant ou en s'abonnant vous
envoie du love et la pisse
le conditionnement classique on va créer
une réponse automatique un stimulus
neutre alors qu'avec le consentement
opérant qu'on va créer une plus haut que
le plus faible probabilité de répéter un
comportement allez allez justement
rapport saleh maintenant ça suffit de
mon revers que la vidéo et vous êtes
plus t'es cool